hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the grantee chess Classic Tournament
here we have a game between Fabiano
Caruana and the Magnus Carlsen so the
winner of the 2018 candidates tournament
against the world chess champion and as
this is only round one I don't really
have any high quality photos for you I
do have this one photo it's not really
of high quality but it will you know set
set the mood I hope so and I don't want
to forget before before showing you the
game I would just like to say that I was
contacted by the grand HS plastic team
the video production team and they said
that if you guys want you can ask
questions in the comments below and they
will use those questions to ask ask the
player so you can ask Carlsen something
you could ask Fabiano something so just
write write the question and say who the
question is is for and use hashtag
question in the comments so it will be
easier to find the questions for for the
players so yeah that being said let's
see this game Fabiano has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 Knight to f6
c4 and here pretty much all of the games
in the candidates tournament went east
six and then after Knight to f3
transposed into d5 and then some g3
carolien ideas but here after c4 Fabiano
goes for g6 Carlsen goes for g6 he
doesn't wanna he doesn't want to go for
something that was already played like
in every game in the candidates Knight
to f3 and now have Bishop to g7 so for
now the Kings Indian defense we have III
call sand castles Bishop to e2 and now
d6 Knight to c3 Knight to c6 and d5
Knight to b4 a3 night to a6 and now
Knight to d4 here a cousin pushes a5 we
have capture some person on e6f captures
on e6 and Caruana castles and e5 Knight
to b3 c6 now II for Knights the c7 and
f4
here we have nine three six and karana
pushes f5 we have night to d4 and here
Bishop to e3
you don't really achieve anything with
night captures on d4 after each captors
and Queen captures on d4 you get Nights
2 G for this opens up an attack from the
bishop to your queen and then you have
all of these ideas here after the Queen
moves you could capture the Queen is
probably coming to h4 but probably after
G captors and a5 Bishop captures the
pawn captures rook after Saint Queen
captures it's why I didn't really get
anything his pieces are still
undeveloped here and black does have a
bishop pair and not really something you
want to do with white so Bishop to e3
we have Knight captures on e2 Queen
captures on e2 and now G captures on f5
e captures on f5 and d5 now seek after
sandy 5c captures on d5 and rook a to D
1 D for now comes Bishop to g5 of course
you can't capture the night the pawn is
pinned Queen to b6 and now Queen the c4
check rook to f7 now comes Knight to a4
attacking the Queen Queen to c7 offering
a trade of Queens Queen captures rook
captures and Knight a to c5 here cousin
plays b6 kicks away that night and now
Bishop captures on f6 and here you have
a choice you either capture the knight
and c5 or you capture the bishop if you
capture the bishop then Knight to e4
this is this is perfectly fine this this
Knight is an excellent piece here and
and the white is white is fine here
so after Bishop captures on f6 we have B
captures on c5 Bishop captures and now
King captures on g7
Knight the d2 we have Bishop to b7 and
here we have this beautiful dark square
bishop light square bishop on this long
diagonal and the Causton does have this
very strong pawn Center so if you look
at it you can immediately sense that
black is better here here karana pushes
f6 with check King to f8 and now rook
II won attacking that if I've born we
have rook to e8 defending and now Knight
to e4 and here it might seem like a
weird idea Carson please Bishop captures
on e4 seems like an like an odd idea
giving up this beautiful bishop but this
night is actually a very powerful piece
here guarding that F born he could maybe
even come to g5 and then and then
prepared to push f7 the h7 would be a
threat so a Carson finds a very nice
plan he plays Bishop captures we have
rook captures and now c4 so already
improving on his game and here g4 by
Caruana and g4 is is a very important
move because Khurana doesn't allow
Carson to simply force this endgame to
how he ever wants to play it here
Khurana pushes g4 would ideas of going
h4 g5 h v g6 and starting starting to
create some counter play of his own we
have rook to b8 and here Carlsen offers
the e5 pawn for the b2 pawn so rook
captures rook capture some b2 and now
rook the rook to d5 attacking the point
c3 now and now rook to see a rope to the
a check of course there's no time to
grab the pawn if you capture it c2 is
coming and a free block it as there's no
other move the rockin c7 is guarding the
pawn rook to be one wins the game easily
so after this C to remove rook to d8
check King moves and now rook to h8
preparing to grab this pawn on h7 and
also pick up the rook Carson brings it
back
rook b2 b6 a rugby to b7 but King to e6
was also an idea and it's interesting
the engine considers King to e6 an
excellent move but he considers this
move Carson played his top choice so a
very nice very nice decision by Carlsen
rook captures King to g6 and now rook
captures on c7 after after the game in
an interview Carson said that he
considered that only after he played
King
g6 he considered that King to g8 was a
much better move and that if he played
into g8 that white can simply resign
here but then then it turned out that
that's really it really wasn't the case
but okay King to g6 rook captures on c7
rook captures on c7 and King to f2 now
King to f2 with the idea that you do
have to get your King into the game now
you do have three points here three
paths to connect and well they're not
connected yet but they could very easily
become connected points so three almost
connected passed pawns against two
connected pens passed pawns Carson has
in the center and here father plays King
to f2 he wants to get his King all the
way here to blockade these pawns and
here Carson has to make a decision and
well the candidate choices are in
captures on f6 grabbing the spawn a rook
to d7 getting this rook behind it this
past pawn or simply pushing pushing this
c2 point immediately so after after a
lot of consideration here across simply
the immediate c2 and this is definitely
this is indeed the strongest move out of
those three rook the c1 you have to
block the pawn and now comes d3 again
the strongest move King to e3 and now
rook to d7 forcing the King to go behind
the past pone so King to d2 and soon for
now Khurana has his rook and his kin
defending against cousins to pass pawns
and now King captures on f6 there was no
time for Caruana ever to push g5 to
protect this f6 pawn here we have H for
this is the only move that allows the
white to continue as you can't allow him
to g5 than all of your King side pawns
will fall so h4 king 25 and now rook to
f1 King to d4 and here Caruana plays h5
after allah after giving this position a
lot of thought there was a very
interesting idea of rook to f4 check but
the problem would look to a four check
is that after king to d5 if you now go
h5 with the idea
that you improve your position because
you kick the King back now comes work to
be seven and after rook to f3 with the
idea of capturing the d3 pawn rook to b3
actually wins the game for black because
now you know you're in a lot of trouble
here
rook captures on d3 simply doesn't work
because rope capture screen captures and
you bring your Queen into the game and
another idea is that after this rook to
be to remove even even if you don't do
anything like this even if you simply
for example push a pawn or something
then you get this c1 and this comes with
check King captures now you check the
King again King captures and I will lose
the rook and this loses the game for
white of course so after King before
Bobby doesn't go for rope to a four he
plays h5 immediately
we have rook to e7 and her rook to e7 is
rook to e7 is like the beginning of a
winning variation but the strongest move
recommended by the engine is actually a
five here and I've seen the coverage it
was commented again by yon Gustavson and
this time Peter like oh and the lake was
said that if you gave this position to
the world's 100 top players and give
them like an hour to analyze it and find
a move for black that probably no one
would find a five because it seems like
it's such a such a tempo tempo variation
and that every tempo is really important
so it doesn't you don't feel like you
really do have the time to push a5 but
you'll see why a five was important here
here cousin played rook to e7 now we
have rook to f4 check King to d5 rook to
f1 now back King to c4 rook to f4 check
King to d5 repeating the move the
position a couple of times
rook to f1 and now back King to c4 rock
to f4 check and now King to be three and
here we have rook to be four check and
this was this was the the importance of
this a5 pawn now there this rook to
before check would not be possible so
okay King captures on a3
look to see for now now the idea of
sacrificing the a pond it becomes clear
now the rook is behind this passed pawn
and it's very hard to play this now for
black King to be three now comes Luke
the c8 again now there's no way to
actually push the C pawn and here
Carlsen played a5 a5 but will will
return to this position here cousin
played a 5 we have h6 by Fabiano rook to
e2 check King capture son d3 rook to h2
now attacking the pawn g5 is coming rook
to h3 pink to d2 rook to h2 check King
to d3 and it was in this position on
move 59 that Fabiano karana and magnus
carlsen drew their first game in the
grand kit in the round one of the grand
HS classic but like i said we should
return to this position where Carson
played this a 5 move if I move was the
strongest move in that position in this
unfortunate support cost and it wasn't
but only after in the interview cousin
saw that if he had played rook to h7
Rock to h7 was the winning move but even
Caruana didn't didn't really see why
this was winning for black but later on
Gustafson explained it to them with the
help of his mighty stockfish that now
because rook to b8 check you get King to
a2 and now after rook to c8 going
stopping the past pawn you get a 5 and
after King captures on d3 now you get
King to be won and now the king we want
move is winning so this is the move date
didn't see because now I have to rook to
b8 check King c1 rook to see it now you
get King to d1 and you don't have the
option of capturing this pawn and Point
C one promoting to a queen is coming of
course if you capture it then this this
check will be deadly
you don't really have a move wherever
you go black will simply capture the
rook you go here then rook will give
another check and top it's game over
so yeah and it doesn't matter those
two connected passed pawns but but life
can easily stop both of them and he does
have a passed pawn of his own so no
problems there so yeah after King to d3
the game was drawn across and did have a
win in a couple of positions but if if
you consider this game by engine's
standards both of them played like an
almost perfect game so cousin missed
like two lines that to improve on he
played like the engines second choice
not not the engines first choice and it
wasn't enough to win so as you can see
by this game were we're gonna have a lot
of fun watching these two brawl it out
in November and I do have I do have one
photo again it's not a very high quality
photo it's from its from the official
Greinke stream but this is them after
the game they just drew their game and
neither of them really think that they
had a chance to win Carson actually
thought that that came to g8 move I
mentioned was winning but in the end it
turns out it really wasn't the way he
continued in the game and here we have
the results of the first round so all of
the games would run except blue bomb
versus the v-cube of which you have won
his game all the other games were drawn
and yeah like I said if you're
interested in asking any of the players
a question just write the question in
the comment section below and use a
hashtag question and of course write for
who who the question is so the Greinke
chess classic video team will probably
use those questions to ask the players
your questions and they will probably
answer them in in their interviews but
yeah I have no idea how this will work
but you know feel free to give it a try
write a question and we'll see what
happens you know nothing that can come
of it so yeah I would like to think I'm
at back here for our conversion to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here
I think oh for watching and I will see
you soon
maybe we would another game from the
Greinke chest bicycle
I didn't have the chance to check out
all of the games yet I've some of the
games were interesting I will show them
and if not we're back to Tarsus
botanique so thank you all and I will
see you soon